hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game between Bobby Fischer and bent
Larsen but not from the 1971 candidates
match but rather from 1958 inter-zonal
tournament in Portage it's one of the
earliest games where young Bobby Fischer
has the white pieces and of course you
all remember the 1958 Porter or
inter-zonal we covered a couple of games
from it we did not cover the entire
tournament but before that we do have a
photo challenge so who is the chess
player in the photo Anais followed by
David Lada also you might have seen her
if you've checked out st. Louis live
coverage she was the official
commentator along the oestrus Aragon so
best of luck to everyone and here we
also have as this game is a suggestion
from a subscriber a gentleman called the
brainless youtuber he says today 16th of
August is the 60th anniversary of a
beautiful game between Bobby and Larson
in the porterage inter-zonal Bobby
included it into his book 60 memorable
games hope you're reading this before
you decide what to do as I did check the
suggestions I found this and okay today
is 17th at least where I live but
nevertheless as 68 60th anniversary and
also it's from 60 my 60 memorable games
so I guess I definitely have to do it
and if any of you are wondering we
already covered Africa vs. Shervin in
Game one from with sixty memorable games
it's also the first game in in the book
this is actually the second game in the
book so kind of funny that worked out
and you all know you'll remember the
final standings of the 1958 porterage
inter-zonal if not here they are just a
glimpse of it but we're gonna check it
out after as well so efore by fisher of
course c5 Knight to f3 d6 d4 C capture
Sun d4 Knight captures in the knight to
f6 Knight to c3 and we have g6 here here
they say that even though in those days
the dragon variation of the Sicilian was
one of blacks the greatest weapons to
fight against efore a lot of attacks
have been found for white and mentors
and he was one of the last people who
was using it on the highest level
they say that like even weaker players
were beating
grandmasters with the white pieces if
they went for the Dragons Sicilian
because D was love attack was very
popular than and you know it was simply
too easy to play it I like Fisher says
and like the title suggests open up the
H file sach sach and mate but let's see
how the game went Bishop to e3 Bishop to
g7 so still in the dragon variation and
now f3 the Yugoslav attack preparing the
potion g4 h4 and whatnot
we have castles by Larson Queen to d2 of
course preparing this Bishop to h6 move
if ever possible Knight to c6 and now
Bishop to c4 Bishop to c4 is an
excellent move before an order variation
was ko queenside castle but if you
Castle queenside you all have like to
put d5 and you know if you allow black
to pull d5 in the Sicilian
you've obviously not done the best you
could have so Fischer here goes for
Bishop to c4 he doesn't allow d5 with
Knight captures on d4 Bishop captures on
d4 and now Bishop to e6
Bishop to b3 by Fischer and now Queen to
a5 Fischer castles Queen side and here
well you could play Bishop captures and
C captures it was a it was kind of a
known thing that black doesn't really
have all that much ideas here how to
break through this pawn structure and
although the pawn structure is much
better for black if you are reaching the
end game but black can never managed to
reach the endgame here white would
simply push G for h4 h5 and simply win
the game
so here Larsson goes for a different
idea he plays b5 and okay King b1 by
Fischer now comes b4 and Knight to d5
here we have Bishop captures on d5
Knight captures on d5 isn't all that
great because it it in the end we will
reach a better position for white for
example Bishop captures on g7 Knights
the c3 as the knight will be lost on d5
so you might as well ruin a white pawn
structure a bit be Capra's on c3 King
captures on g7 ends in Aussie capture
son before would an attack on the Queen
Queen moves now comes Queen d4 check
King moves and now Bishop captures on e6
pawn captures and you move the Queen
back you are
and you have an excellent game so
instead after night instead of night
captures Bishop characters was played
Bishop captures and here after the game
Larsen mentioned the disposition and he
said that he wanted to win this game he
was playing for a win in this game even
though he saw that night captures only
if I was a forced to draw because after
he captures Queen captures for example
rook to e1 and now Queen captures Bishop
on d4 there's no way to stop this Queen
captures Bishop captures rook captures
and now the e7 point ended the the b4
poner under attack so you want to
protect the b4 pawn rook captures and
now rook to e8 captures captures where
black is now threatening Brooke to e1
checkmate King c1 and now after a rookie
to the game continues but the material
is equal this is this is a drone endgame
so instead as time on of did not want to
draw as sorry time on we already we had
so many time on of games I'm constantly
thinking Fischer is playing against time
on of Larson here mentions that he did
not want this draw variation that we
mentioned so instead he went rook to c8
and here Fischer says he immediately
went to Bishop to b3 he says if you
haven't taken my bishop now you will not
have it and now he says that he achieved
so many easy victories with this setup
where he simply pushes g4 h4 h5 he sucks
piece and then checkmates his opponent
so let's see if this is true Larson
wants to push his 8th 7th pawn on the
Queen side but to do this he has to move
the Queen and also to move the Queen he
has to defend the pawn so first rook the
c7 freshman starts his attack on the
King side h4 queen b5 preparing to move
the a pawn h5 we have rook F to c8
doubling on the C file and now H
captures in g 6h factors on g6 and the
g4 favour prepares g5 we have a 5 and
now comes g5 attacking the knight and
here you don't have all that many
options you can go Knight H 5 98 you can
push a for pushing a for doesn't work
because you simply capture here and
after a captures you can capture the
bishop and now after pawn captures on c2
this comes with
check it seems like it's an excellent
move but White has this beautiful Queen
captures on c2 and now there's really
nothing to do if you capture the Queen
then rope to h8 is checkmate and even if
you don't capture the Queen if you play
something like f6 still it will not help
you Queen h2 and then it's all over
another thing you could do after g5 is
going Knight 898 also isn't that great
because of Bishop captures knife
characters and then now look to h6 queen
is coming to h2 then again it's all over
for black so the amount of try Larsson
tries a knight to h5 but here comes a
Fisher's main idea that he always
mentions why and you shouldn't play the
dragon Sicilian or the Pierce defense
because g4 h4 h5 and then rook captures
here and it's all over as Fischer says G
captors n h5 was played and now g6 not
wasting any time the f7 pawn is pinned
'if I've attacking the bishop now pawn
captures on f7 King to f8 and now comes
Bishop to e3
d5 we have eek a person d5 there's even
time for that rope to f7 and now comes
d6 opening up an attack against the rook
on f7 roof to f6 blocking and now comes
Bishop to g5 Queen to b7
okay we have Bishop captures on f6
Bishop captures on f6 and here Fischer
played d7 but it's not the only way to
go although white here does have a
checkmate in 7 moves Fischer goes for
one line but also a very beautiful line
is Queen to h6 check not an easy one to
find because after Queen blocks you have
this beautiful look to g1 move and now
you cannot capture the rub because the
Queen is pinned if you do nothing then
rook captures queen is coming and if you
capture the Queen here then you get rook
the g8 and this will be checkmate but ok
after Bishop to f6
first plate d7 instead of Queen to h6 we
have grouped to the eight and now Queen
to d6 check and it was in this position
that been lost and resigned to the game
as there is really nothing to do here if
you try Bishop to e7 blocking then Queen
to h6 will be checkmate the point is
guarding the eights where Bush regarding
the this entire light squared
you know and if instead after Queen d6
you go King g7 it doesn't matter
Rosie one check King moves you get Queen
captures on f6 and now whatever you play
the defense checkmate you're still
getting checkmated Queen g6 check King
moves Queen Queen captures here twin
blocks Queen captures on e5 you have to
block and a now Queen captures on g7
will be checkmate again so yeah Queen d6
I was in this position that bent Larsen
resigned the game but like he said in
this infamous position were better to
defy was played he did not want to go
for a night capture Sun d5 he said he
saw the forced to draw line but as
special was still very young and Ben
Carson wanted to ensure his place in the
1959 candidates tournament he wanted to
go for a win here
I like we said these are the final
standings as you all know towel won this
tournament with 13 and a half out of 20
after that he of course qualified for
the 1959 the legendary tournament which
he won and then of course went to the
fight Botvinnik but you know as you can
see here James bent Larsen was not able
to qualify he had at 8 and 8 and a half
out of 20 and Fischer Indian had 12 out
of 20 along with Fredrik Hall awesome so
yeah that's the game a nice preparation
for our 1971 match between FIFA on arson
which I'm planning to start tomorrow so
I do hope you enjoyed this game that
you're enjoying the official series so
far this is just an introduction I would
like to thank Mario sector for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video see or
think all for watching and I will see
you soon with the Bobby Fischer series
and on a side note if any of you are
perhaps interested in hearthstone I also
create some hearthstone content so I
will put a couple of links in the
description below in case you want to
check that out as well thank you all and
I'll see you soon